i was overweight basically my whole life
and when i think back to myself as a kid
i wasn't
so overweight that i was
mere sedentary or anything like that but
then
over time it just compounds and it gets
bigger and bigger and
the day that i kind of was confronted
with
everything it was almost as though i was
unaware of it
a moment before the idea that my knees
and my feet
constantly hurt my back would go out i'd
slip
discs in my back a number of times that
i sat down
in such a way as to test the
you know the tensile strength of
everything i was sitting on
for fear that i was gonna break it
having to have a washcloth in my pocket
at all times to mop my brow which i
would
like in the middle of a conversation
with somebody kind of turn and
and do it all of these little things
you're unaware
that this is kind of unnecessary
in your life that there is a solution to
all of this
until the day that you wake up and you
go i have to change
and i understand for people you can have
that thought a thousand times
and still not do anything which i'm sure
i did
and then there's just one day where it's
like i'm not going to
not think about this anymore this isn't
going to be something that i allow
to go to the recesses of my mind or
i push away when it comes up